now let's send it to mercedes to learn
more about awareness when it comes to
long-term care
i'm here to help educate us on why this
is such an important topic is author and
long-term care specialist susan d
marshall the sponsor of this segment
it's great to have you back susan you
have such a great information for people
this is stuff that people need to plan
for so can you explain what exactly
long-term care is well thank you
mercedes that's a good question though
because long-term care is more than just
nursing home care one of the most
common types of care people need as they
age is personal care
assistance with those activities of
daily living
someone to help you with eating dressing
bathing moving from your bed to a chair
but here's the catch
because it's considered personal care
and not long-term care i mean
medical care
for this reason it's not covered by your
health insurance or medicare you're
kidding so when you're in a situation
where you need this
how
how much does that cost
the cost can be considerable especially
for the non-medical care
so
assume you need help for part of the day
and it could run anywhere from four to
eight thousand dollars per month and
over three years period
well over two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars so we do want to make sure
someone has a plan in place
to help protect their
their assets
is there a certain segment of people
that need to be concerned about
long-term care i would say everyone i
speak to so many people
often and they say you know i am not
worried about me
but i need something for my mama or my
brother or
fill in the blank but
unfortunately a unplanned health care
crisis does not discriminate by your age
it could happen to you your spouse
even a child and if you're the last one
standing
who's going to take care of you
so yeah that's really important you
always assume that this is just
something for my parents but yeah you
never know what's going to happen so if
this is not covered by medical insurance
how in the world are people supposed to
pay for something like this
that's something i do try to help them
do is we do need to look at
ways that we can help them figure out
how to pay for those types of expenses
and put a plan in place and that's
probably the most important thing is to
put a properly structured plan in place
to help protect
you and your family but you need to do
it ahead of the unplanned event earlier
now what do you recommend that people do
to plan
i would say give me a call and set up a
free consultation because
it needs to be something that you can
design based on your own personal needs
yeah just talking to you you give such
great information on this and again this
is not something that you plan for you
want to make sure that
heaven forbid something happen you're
ready to go how do our viewers get in
touch with you
by all means give me a call because we
went to set up the free
initial consultation but most
importantly i want to be able to give
you a gift and take advantage or take me
up on that offer and call and get your
copy of my book
protecting your future with tax-free
long-term care it really she really does
know what she's talking about and what i
think is the best part is you're really
empathetic to everybody's needs and
you're really here to help so thank you
so much for all the information and the
time susan d marshall sponsoring this
segment we are so grateful for her
information if you want more visit set
to retire.com and we have a special
offer for you guys the first 100 callers
to call 702-546-8825